[Music]
let's go to
jennifer in birmingham what is up
jennifer
hey dr john how are you taking my call
i'm doing um i just want you to know too
that your show i'm sure lots of people
tell you this but your show does make a
difference and it's made me take like a
long hard look at my life
well number one
nobody tells me that so thank you even
my wife is like can you just let's mow
lawns let's have a family lawn bowling
business um your show's terrible so
thank you so much um that really means a
lot to me and
the
you're the one doing the work and so i'm
proud of you for
like man leaning in and making some hard
changes in your life um talk directly on
your phone cause i wanna make sure i
don't miss this um what's going on in
your world
okay um i'm gonna make it short and
sweet or cut right to the point um i
grew up in an abusive household um i
heard obviously by listening to you
already i've heard about your aces scale
so i'm a six on that and now um 15 years
out of that you know leaving that home
and everything i'm now a single mom of
two great girls and um my question to
you is it is it too late for me to heal
from my childhood trauma oh what an
awesome question jennifer did you know
almost nobody asks that question
that's incredible good for you
um
i can answer that question but for the
sake of radio can we dig into some of
the past stuff are you okay with that
sure yeah sure um
the simple answer is yes and i'm so glad
that you asked that absolutely one
million percent yes
um so tell me about your childhood
um well i had um my biological father
was absent so basically from you know
most of my first couple years it was
just me and my mom and while she was
trying to get her life together you know
i was bounced around at different family
homes and then she met a guy married him
he adopted me and
they have a very volatile relationship
there were
obviously
there was physical abuse verbal abuse my
mom didn't really stand up for herself
so as the only child for almost the
first 10 years of my life i felt the
need to insert myself because you know
that's my mom she shouldn't take that
and then um there were some times where
i don't know if she meant to or not i
guess you don't know if anyone does but
she had some suicide attempts and so it
was just
it was a long 15 years and then i ended
up
leaving um
halfway through my senior year of high
school and went to live with my
grandparents and that kind of ripped it
all wide open because you know we don't
kind of like calling you today we don't
air laundry or skeletons in public and
most people wouldn't have known if um i
guess if they just didn't really really
know us or anything i guess we were good
at keeping our business in the house
wow wow and so what happened in your
marriage
um
honestly i
maybe i wasn't mentally
prepared for it does that make sense um
i ended up
i don't think i don't think any of us
are mentally prepared for marriage i
don't know i think i um we we got
pregnant before we got married and so i
think we got married trying to do the
right thing and um i've listened to some
of your other shows and i could kind of
i kind of you know in my 30s now you
know he and i are civil we've done great
at co-parenting we've been divorced for
um you know seven or eight years now
it's just we did not um it's kind of
like having an extra child and i i had
just enough for me and my kids and
that's not really an excuse i know i
played a part in it but um i don't know
i guess my focus too and that sounds
awful too at the time i wasn't focused
on being the best spouse ever i was just
from my childhood on i just if i ever
had kids i wanted to make sure that i
was better than the hand i was dealt and
we had a rough go and i didn't want to
be one of those people that stayed in a
miserable marriage like my parents are
25 years later
gotcha gotcha
um
and thanks for sharing that so
give me
give me a rundown of the last six seven
years
what's up in life um
well it was um kind of i guess getting
divorced kind of added stress but it was
also a release at the same time you know
i'm standing on my own two feet i have
two great girls they're now um both at
that preteen puberty age which has been
really fun um but like i said i've
worked really hard you know even you
know getting pregnant in college my kids
are 11 months apart so you know i did
really good planning that as well but i
i never took time off you know i
finished college i have a full-time job
i'm a manager i do great my kids see
that i work hard um
i am
recently diagnosed with add which makes
sense a lot first of all
yeah exactly exactly and i got bored um
you know a couple years into my divorce
and decided i needed a second degree
because you know school and work and
everything wasn't enough i needed
something else to like keep me going so
they've seen me you know work hard for
everything i do that's important i try
to make their world as safe and calm as
possible um but
i guess
my grandma died a few years ago and i
guess that's kind of random but she was
my rock in the world you know she knew
all of the pain i was going through and
i could come to her there was no
judgment she was my person in my life
who you know told me she was proud of me
told me she loved me there was no
manipulation or anything else or i never
worried about going you know to her
house or like you know my house i did
everything i could to get out of it and
so um but she passed away a few years
ago and that was kind of a um
i don't know it was like something
clicked and i realized i didn't have
anyone to lean on anymore and um my
parents are still in my life but i draw
very hard boundaries and even when i try
to reach out you know medical issues
come up things with my kids other stuff
they just it's just a repeated
disappointment if that makes sense so i
have this gap in my life and um growing
up i was you know in survival mode
constantly so it didn't really affect me
now but the further i get away from that
um the more it tries to resurface so you
know i my only tool apparently in my
tool belt is this rusty old shovel
because i bury everything now every time
it rains in my life a little it's just
coming to the surface
so i'm trying to find healthy ways
without you know dropping a jug of milk
you know on the floor and then just
having a meltdown because that's not
realistic and that's not why i'm
you know having a meltdown yes
so
first and foremost you're so brave
what i mean
like i'd hug you if i'd ask you but i'd
hug you if you were sitting here like
um you've been through it
and you're working so hard
it's it's so admirable how you are con
you're standing at the helm of that ship
and you are leaning on it to turn the
thing around
so hard and you have been for so long
and it's admirable how you're using your
strength is so good
um
so you said you've been in flight since
when you were a little kid just
constantly on the go and what i would
tell you is after talking to you for
three minutes
your um
your engine runs hot
and so i wrote down a few things you
said um
you're providing a safe calm world for
your daughters
i'm just gonna make some guesses here
does your safe and calm come through
organization
and uh cleanliness and routine planning
yes planning i i spring clean 15 times a
year where people probably think i'm
compulsive but my parents were also
hoarders too and it's just
i have to have my i'm not like a mean
controlling person i just have to know
what's going on for us to you know flow
okay so number one
you're still in fight or flight and you
have been for how old are you 31
32 yeah 32 so you have been for about 30
years
okay
and in counseling we say we call it
leakage which is
you can deal with this stuff or it will
deal with you and it usually picks the
most inopportune times
like you say like it's just
i'm making cereal for my daughter and i
dropped the milk
and all of a sudden six minutes later
i'm on the floor and i can't breathe and
my i have an 11 year old looking at me
thinking like asking what happened to
mommy right or you're prepping for
um a work presentation or you are
all are you always almost late are you
always on time
um i try to be on time say i knew it you
were almost always late
we yeah
we were pushing you know we're pushing
down the barrel which it doesn't help
that my job is a little flexible so it's
not that i have to punch the clock as
long as i'm there within like a ballpark
time
um keep it going because now you're
making me feel like um i'm uh like
i'm smarter than i am and then when
you're at work sometimes you have entire
blocks where you just stay off into
space or you will youtube down a rabbit
hole
um
a few hours after your kids go to bed
you will get more done and it will be
outstanding work
and then you know like that boss is
loving today but yeah
and then you get mad at yourself like
why can't i just do this during the day
that's so ridiculous and then you loop
back and then the whole thing starts
over you are
um
here's my guess my guess is the little
girl in you stood between mom and
abusive guy and she tried to fight
and she learned at an early age
that
her muscles were little and her voice
was little and she saw what happens when
her mom who's the model for a woman in
her life stands up to a guy it ends
really badly
and you shifted from fighting to running
and
when you have a traumatic childhood when
you have a traumatic adulthood which a
divorce is i know it happens all the
time and we un we under appreciate how
heavy it is
um even like you said you could finally
breathe for the first time you stood up
on your own two feet but you actually
anchored to somebody else and then that
somebody else passed away you realized
oh no i'm totally untethered
um
then we just start running
and we run through achievement we run
through accomplishment we burn through
relationships and we are
parent always exhausted right
um yeah and then you said this
here's the other part
and this is a common thing with adhd
folks this this is a common thing with i
think adhd is one of it's just a marker
of
childhood chaos
um
you still have this fantasy that you're
holding out for
that
one day i'm going to call mom and dad
and they're going to say the right
things that mom and dads are supposed to
say when they have a sick grandkid or
when their daughter's exhausted
even how you said
oh this is kind of random but my grandma
died
it's super not random
but when you're running from everything
you have to just let it it's like you're
sprinting and your buddy gets picked off
by the by the tiger you just you're like
uh well i gotta keep going
is that is that fair
yes it is it is and i i do get burned
out and there are times where it's like
i don't know like you're saying i'm not
tethered i'm i'm blowing freely in the
wind and i know people look around me
and i don't really know what normal is
but they're not running on my level and
they're like you know why do you need
this why do you act like that don't look
at me and are you okay what is okay i'm
fine i'm here i'm ready and hey here's
the other thing
we live in a culture that rewards that
i can outwork you i can work longer than
you i can turn in better stuff and
quicker stuff and more aggressive stuff
and i can be louder and direct and cool
and great and super fun and when i
collapse that's on my own time
and my paycheck goes up my promotions go
up
my performance goes up and inside
my body
i haven't changed the oil in 30 years
and eight years is a long time to be
lonely too as a 31 year old with two
little girls
and
i heard an attorney say this one so i
was working with some attorneys and
they
one of them said this and i had a friend
and she had the same exact experience
and here's my guess on you the attorney
we were talking about stuff and she said
or he said i feel like if i ever cried
if i just stopped and cried i would
never be able to stop
and my question to you is
if you ever just
stopped for a minute
and exhaled
and thought about grandma
and thought about five-year-old jennifer
standing between mom
and this complete buffoon of a human
and
nine-year-old jennifer wondering what
was so wrong with jennifer that mom
won't talk to me
and man i miss grandma
and again i miss grandma
if you ever slow down and sat in that
for a minute
or just as i'm explaining that tell me
what you're feeling
i'm flashing honestly to there's times
and um
you know i haven't found somebody you
know definitive to talk to and i guess
that's why i'm coming to you today
because listening to your podcast gives
some kind of clarity but i've had
moments in the last few months or years
even that um
you know it's like i'll be scrubbing the
bathroom and i start crying and i did i
i ran out it was like the anniversary of
my grandma died and i went and sat on
the porch for an hour and a half which
thankfully my kids weren't there so i
had the freedom to do that but there are
times where if i let it flow then it's
like i can't pull myself back out for a
couple days yeah and i don't i guess i
just i need to but i i in my head i
can't afford to just sit and do that
because i have kids that depend on me
and don't understand you know all the
things that i've seen in my life and the
things i hope they never see and
so it's just hard i guess i'm gonna tell
you something but you're gonna have to
promise me
you have to promise that you're not
gonna internalize it
okay okay you promise
i promise you say i put your hand over
your heart liar i'm just kidding you're
out there okay
and then say i promise
i promise okay
our kids
i'm a runner too
and that's i'm trying to sound like i'm
all smart all those things i just said
it's because i live that
okay
i'm a runner big time
and
one of the most jarring and important
moments of my life was when i came to
realize that i can do things for my kids
and i can tell them things
but they absorb
that internal tension
they absorb it as though it is the blood
flowing through their veins
and they also see me smile concocted
smile when inside my heart's racing a
thousand miles an hour because i'm
anxious and i didn't sleep last night
because i was thinking about this thing
that happened a long time ago and here i
go here we go here we go
and they see me smile and they see me
make breakfast
and they feel
that's not him
there's a gap
and so what i would tell you is now
often when i'd say that somebody you're
going to look in the mirror and
internalize it and say i'm a bad mom i
screw i'm screwing up my daughter it's
the same thing i'm recur i'm creating
patterns all that stuff
don't do that okay you are working so
hard all this is now is a matter of of
energy transference okay
and you said you've got two daughters
that you got to take care of you got to
make sure they don't have x y and z the
greatest gift you can give them is a
vulnerable mom
is a mom that shows them what grieving
looks like that when you cry they get to
see that and they get to see hey it's
okay to cry and then
we smile and then we go get ice cream or
then we all go for a walk or then we go
get up and do our next thing
because what happens is they're gonna
cry one day and they're gonna have no
model for it
something will happen as much as we
don't want something to happen to our
kids something will happen to our kids
and if they've never seen us do it
experience it be honest about it bring
them into that
they it happens to them and they end up
on an island
and they think man my mom handled it
like that or dad was able to do this and
they don't know so the greatest gift you
can give your daughters
is
if they're young obviously you're not
going to tell them the full extent but
letting them know and tyler was really
hard it was hard growing up
and i miss my daddy and i really miss
grandma and sometimes i cry because i
miss grandma it makes me so so sad
um i've had a family member passed away
very very recently and the question i
asked my wife today when i was making
plane arrangements to go to the funeral
was i want to take one of my kids with
me
i want them to see that
um and so
we're talking about how we get them out
of school and all this but that's that's
how important it has become to me
so the greatest gift
hear me say this the greatest gift you
can give to your kid
is you
and what you're doing right now is
running as hard as you can so that
nobody can actually see you
they're trying you're trying to create
shiny things and markers and metals and
trophies so they can point to those
things because somewhere along the way
you got the message
that jennifer has very little value
and that to answer your original
question that's where the healing from
childhood trauma starts
that jennifer's got value
warts and all
does that make sense
yeah and i know that's heavy right
so to answer your answer your original
original question in some detail dude
yes you for sure can heal
for sure
um
asking that question is step number one
step number two is the hardest thing for
somebody with a sick let me let's just
so let's
back up the aces score is not mine i
wish i was that smart i am not that
smart that's dr nadine burke harrison a
whole truck like trauma researchers that
came up with that um she's a brilliant
brilliant brain um but it's a 10 for
those who are listening it's a 10
question scale
that just rates childhood trauma and
what we know is if you have a four or
higher on this scale and it's everything
from
would you be in a household of divorce
did you see abuse does somebody that in
your immediate house will go to jail
because you were around addiction and
things like that
some things that we would think would be
benign or some things that when you add
them up it's this cumulative nature if
you have a four or higher it's when you
get into some really bizarre
correlations
cause causative correlations right not
even correlations or causations you see
an increase in cancers and you see an
increase in strokes and increase in
heart attacks things that you would
never
like this happen as a kid and people get
cancer more that's weird and what
they're finding is our bodies stay in
these inflamed states for years and
years and years and years they're
fighting and running and freezing from
everything
and until we can
let our bodies know that right now we're
safe right now we're okay
it will continue to fight for us and
fight for us and fight for us and fight
for us year after year after year later
and that sounds like woo it's not in
fact the aces work the trauma work has
just been extraordinary
um
so step number one for you and this is
going to be the hardest one
when you grew up in an abusive
relationship or with neglect one of
those two narratives told you something
about relationships and your role in
them
does that make sense
yeah so if you're if you are abused
physically sexually actually if you're
abused
you get a very clear message about your
worth
your body's worth your space in in the
world's worth
and you learn that people are not safe
or if you're neglected if mom is an
addict mom is going through her own
physical or mental health challenges you
are on the back burner all the time
she's too caught up in her new marriage
or she's she's an abuser whatever the
thing is if there's neglect
then the child gets a very clear message
that i am less than i don't have value
these other things are more important
than me and then kids will spend the
rest of their life trying to solve for
what was wrong with me
you had both
right
yes and so
the the really challenging part here is
the only thing that helps that healing
process is relationships and for someone
in your position those were the things
that hurt you
so my guess is you've tried have you
tried a counselor and you go once or
twice or you talk to a pastor or a
friend or once or twice and then you
bail out
yeah i don't know if it's because if
it's if it's me making excuses or it
just doesn't line up or yes there's
you know hey let's unpack the past and
they're like well let's just focus on
right now or you know let's let's not
worry about your mom or anything else so
then i don't know i had one tell me
before that i was just born and i needed
to pick up an art class or something so
oh man
see i was having a good time on this
show and now you got me all raged out
because i can't stand terrible
counselors no i'm just kidding it's not
you it's just i can't
the courage it takes to go see a
counselor to go see a psychologist is so
it takes so much courage to go
and if you get some nonsensical [ __ ]
like that that tells you things like
that
it makes my blood boil because you you
you can lose somebody and when you lose
somebody with two little kids you can
lose a generation
right that's why it's so important for
counselors to know in the world they're
doing that crazy crazy jennifer i'm
sorry on behalf of all therapists in the
country i'm sorry that happened to you
that should not have happened
um i would recommend looking for a
someone trained in
childhood trauma and a trauma therapist
in your local area
and
it will be expensive and it will be
worth every penny you pay for it
and i would let them know your past and
i would probably spend some time writing
this down
two or three or four or six or 10 pages
however much comes out
but telling your story so that when you
get in that room you have so many
defense mechanisms and so many diversion
techniques to deal with relationships
it's how you've gotten this far
you'll be able to read it and say here's
what i'm dealing with
and here's who i need somebody to walk
alongside me
and let's draw some connections to
nowadays
but the answer is yes finding somebody
to talk to finding someone to walk
alongside and then you're going to begin
to
feel these things as they happen and
what will happen over time is you'll
drop the milk and you will feel it come
over your body and you'll instantly be
able to back out of it
and say what is this response
why is my body responding like this
that feels weird it's curiosity instead
of judgment right
and
slowly practicing that some of it will
be with trauma work whether that's emdr
whether that is
um you know somatic positioning there's
all these different ways that you can
work that trauma out of your body but
it's held up in there
and
some of it will be talking some of it
will be doing some hard trauma work so
we'll be doing some writing some of it
will be doing some practicing
relationships maybe groups maybe taking
your daughters and doing x number of
things some of it will be being really
vulnerable and it will be really scary
for you because vulnerability got you
hurt a lot right
yeah
and some of it will be meditation so you
can learn how to control your thoughts
so when they start to take over you can
walk it back and what i'll tell you
that's probably the part that you
believe the least and i'm telling you as
someone who's walked this journey
now it's just remarkable how you can
just back up i can back way up real
quick and that's just years of just
sitting and working in it
so you're 31 my guess is if you make
this a priority and you say mom's gonna
get well and i'm gonna raise two
daughters who are not only strong and
powerful and able to defend
themselves but who know how to laugh
until their guts hurt
and they know how to dance like bananas
and they know how to be strong and
negotiate
and they know how to weep bitterly and
they know how to grieve i'm going to
reach those kind of daughters because
i'm going to learn those skills
so instead of thinking about this as a
you're broken and you've got to get
fixed think of this as i'm 31 i'm going
to spend the next two three four years
learning a whole bunch of new skills
and in the process of learning those
skills your body will reconnect with
itself
and you will be able to sleep with no
medication
you'll be able to sleep without having
to scroll through instagram or watch
five netflix shows
you'll be able to date without worrying
am i good enough for this [ __ ] whatever
goofball sitting across from you it's
whatever table
and you'll be able to laugh
when you drop the milk instead of fall
apart does that sound like
how does it sound
that sounds well everything you
described is exactly me um but yeah that
would that would be incredible because
you know i try but there are times where
i know i fall short and i've i've made
an effort to i apologize to my kids
anytime you know if i get a short temper
or you know my patience runs out or
something i always come back and
apologize and tell them you know it's
not you mommy loves you i promise you
know i'm i'm working through or doing
whatever so i do try i probably don't do
it as much as i need to but i do try
even a little bit to be
vulnerable with them because i want them
to know that it's okay to have feelings
only
an extraordinary
brave woman with an aces score of six
would turn forgiveness into a tally mark
or a performance
only
only jennifer not only jennifer only a
extraordinary powerful strong brilliant
woman who's got an asus grove six would
say
no i do i tell my daughters that um i
ask for their forgiveness and i tell
them i'm sorry but i could probably do
it better and i'll start working harder
at making forgiveness more of a thing
and i'm gonna make a chart and then
here's what i want jennifer to do
tonight okay
i want you to
number one before this week is over
i want you to have made a call and an
appointment with a somebody in your area
who specializes in trauma
okay and you can google that you can
look at psychology today you can look at
any number of places you can have
somebody at work
find a trauma counselor in your area and
i want you to go see them
you don't have to go see him this week
but i want there to be something on the
books
the second thing i want you to do is i
want you to write a letter
to eight-year-old jennifer our
seven-year-old jennifer
and start with dear seven-year-old
jennifer
my god you're so beautiful
and i want you to describe what she's
wearing
and then i want you to let her know
this isn't her fault
and it wasn't her job to defend mom
it wasn't her job to stand up to an
abusive husband it wasn't her fault that
dad left
and once you let that girl go play
she's still at she's still working and i
want you to let her know she can clock
out and go play
is that cool
yeah
i can be able to do that
yes do you promise
i promise all right hand over my heart
you have to i knew it liar i'm just
kidding you're not liar i don't know why
i'm saying call you a liar you're not
liar at all uh it just sounds like so
dismissive and ridiculous um when you
write yourself that letter don't send it
but i you have to this is the rules you
gotta send a note to kelly that said i
did my homework
okay cool
and after your first um after your first
appointment
i want you to write us back and let us
know how it went and it will probably be
rough especially if you write
write something that you can read to the
to the counselor there it's going to get
past all of your all of your weapons and
all of your diversion techniques and if
you are a person who's had an abusive
childhood or who's got a high ace of
score um you know exactly what i'm
talking about when you're walking to a
credit room and just direct traffic
because it keeps them from looking at
you
to anybody listening
number one recognize jennifer for the
brave soul that she is
if anyone else is for everyone listening
it is never too late to hear from heal
from trauma ever ever ever
that's why i do the show it's never too
late 72 52 22 10. it's never too late to
heal from tama
ever and it starts with looking in the
mirror and saying
i'm losing control of my breath and my
sleep it's probably time
i want
more for myself i want this is the magic
word
i want peace
jennifer you're
absolute rock star thanks for calling
and we'll walk alongside with you i hope
that we can stay connected for the next
year or two as you walk through this
and i can't wait to
man i can't wait to
meet jennifer in person on the back end
of this when um she's going to bed with
no medicine getting up with only one cup
of coffee it's gonna be great